problema número 138 era un mercader o
cada trabajador del turno nocturno carga
tres cuartas partes de las cajas que
carga cada uno de los trabajadores del
turno de día
si el turno nocturno tiene cuatro
quintos del número de trabajadores del
turno de día qué fracción del total de
las cajas cargadas fueron entregadas por
el turno de día
al no tenemos los datos que nos dan nos
están diciendo que las cajas cargadas
por el turno nocturno son igual a tres
cuartas partes
de las cajas del turno de día también
nos dicen que los trabajadores del turno
de la noche es igual a cuatro quintos
de los trabajadores del turno de 10 los
trabajadores de día y lo que nos
preguntan es qué cuál fue lo hecho por
los trabajadores del día
con las cajas de día con respecto a toda
la producción total o la carga total de
ambos turnos que es lo he hecho por el
tour los trabajadores del día con las
cajas que cargaron en el día más lo
realizado por los trabajadores de la
noche con las cajas que cargaron en la
noche para simplificar esto vamos a
sustituir cnn tengo que cn vale esto y
tn vale esto
estos son los sustituyó acá me va a
quedar de de cede arriba
/
td
de más tn es esto cuatro quintos de té
de cuatro quintos
de por
cn que estos cuartos de cede tres
cuartos
de c d
ok vamos a simplificar aquí este 4 se va
con este 4 me queda
dv esta es una de los pelotas de de cd
/
td
se ve más tres quintos tres quintos
de c de c de c de y como tengo los
mismos términos en todos estos elementos
voy a dividir numerador y denominador
entre cdc de esto me va a quedar como 1
entre uno más tres quintos un entero es
igual a cinco quintos cinco quintos más
tres quintos es igual a
8 quintos
esto es igual a cinco octavos
es mi opción
veamos el siguiente problema la comida
de un restaurante cuesta 35 con 50 y no
tiene impuestos si la propiedad fue
mayor que el 10% pero menor al 15% del
costo de la comida en qué rango de
cantidades estará el costo total r si el
costo de la comida más la propina nos
dicen que la propina es
mayor que el 10%
pero menos
el 15 por ciento
el 10% de esta cantidad es de 3.55
y para sacar el 15% a este 10% le tengo
que agregar la mitad de esta cantidad y
la mitad de 3.55 es un 1.55 los sumamos
3.55 + 1.775 775 esto es 5 2 3
5.325 así que la propia cne está entre
estas cantidades
5.325
ahora lo que nos resta para encontrar la
cantidad total pues es sumar el costo de
la comida
35.5 3.55 estos mas 39.5 que fue el
costo de la comida
5 10 llevamos 113 114 43.5
lo menos que se pudo haber pagado esto
es la cantidad de menor del total este
su lote del total que es menor a su vez
de esta cantidad 5.325 + 39.5 el costo
de la comida 39.5
8 puntos de este es un 8
95 14 llevamos 14 44.800 25
ese es el rango del costo total de la
comida incluyendo la propina y esta es
mi opción de opción b
muy bien veamos el siguiente problema
problema número 140 en una competencia
de levantamiento de pesas el peso total
de los dos levantamientos de juan fue de
750 kilos si el doble de peso del primer
levantamiento fue de 300 kilogramos más
que el segundo levantamiento cuál fue el
peso en kilogramos del primer
levantamiento nos dicen que el
levantamiento 1 o el primer
levantamiento más el segundo
levantamiento el total fue de 750 pero
también nos dicen que el doble del
primer levantamiento es igual a 300
kilos más que el segundo levantamiento
de esta primera ecuación podemos
despejar el 2 y sustituirlo en la
segunda ecuación aquí l 2 es igual a 750
menos l 1 lo sustituimos aquí y nos
queda que 12 l 1 es igual a 300
+ 750
- l 1
300 a 750 va a ser igual a 1050
sumamos el e1 en ambos lados y nos queda
aquí que es 3 l 1 y aquí se va está el
león 30 nos iguala 1050 l uno va a ser
igual a 1050 entre 3
y esto está división es igual a 350 que
es nuestra opción d
veamos el siguiente problema problema
número 141 un club
recolectó exactamente 599 de sus
integrantes si cada integrante
contribuyó con al menos 12 cuál es el
mayor número de integrantes que puede
tener el club se reconectó a una
cantidad de 599 y al menos al menos cada
uno de los integrantes aportó 12
vemos que todos sonaron exactamente 12
si esta cantidad de 599 fuera 600 no sé
por redondear y hacer una operación
rápida 600 entre 12 nos daría 50
tendríamos 50 integrantes pero no fueron
600 lo que se aportó en total sino 599
este no es el caso nuestro máximo de
personas es 49 nuestro máximo nuestra
máxima cantidad de integrantes de este
club es de 49 personas que es la opción
c pero vamos a verificar vamos a
multiplicar 49 por 12 a ver cuánto nos
da 49 por 12
9 x 2 18
llevamos una 4 x 2 819 aquí es 49 por
unos 49 sumamos
8 18 llevamos 15 588
cada uno hubiera contribuido exactamente
con 12 tendríamos 558 aunque quizás
otras no se 11 personas donaron 13 en
lugar de 12
no podemos tener 50 personas porque cada
integrante pagó cuando menos 12 y de ser
así si hubieran recabado los 600 así que
confirmamos nuestra opción el siguiente
problema
número 142 de los 3.600 empleados de la
compañía x un tercio son oficinistas si
la cantidad de oficinistas se va a
reducir en un tercio y el porcentaje del
total de los empleados restantes serán
oficinistas los oficinistas en este
momento es una tercera parte de la
cantidad total de empleados que es de
esto es igual a 1200
pero nos dicen que un tercio de los
oficinistas son despedidos un tercio
y 1200 es igual a 400 así que vamos a
quitar estos 400 a los 1200 que había
originalmente 1200 menos 400 es igual a
800 800 qué proporción será esto con
respecto al resto de los empleados bueno
no olvidemos que de los 3.600 empleados
se despidieron 400 así que a 3600 le
quitamos 400 y nos va a quedar 3200 la
proporción nos va a quedar 800 quedan
nuestros oficinistas que quedaron 800
entre 3.200
en 8 x 4 32 si esto lo vivimos entre 800
nos va a quedar uno entre 4 14 y esta es
la opción a el 25 por ciento
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo